you and I are talking to each other
right now through technology had there
been no in this [ __ ] Corona happened
in 88
we'd all be [ __ ] not interacting
really isolated we demonize technology
when technology brings happiness
[Music]
you got your perspective you're on this
beautiful Tuesday March 24th and I'm
excited to be with all of you guys over
but he's doing well I know the current
situation has a lot of people in
different places and I'm here to some
tea and answer some Q&A thank you for
everybody joining thank you for people
joining to a community Facebook
Instagram all the platforms we're live
on Facebook please share the link and
Madison here on Gary good what's up dude
haha how are you it's going well how are
you pretty good man not gonna lie I
haven't woke up this early in a while
it's been back-to-back mornings I'm in
Arizona right now so it's like 6:00 in
the morning nothing much well first it
was funny because I came and saw you in
LA and I actually met d-roc in the
bathroom and I and I pissed right next
phone so it was pretty funny didn't talk
in that manner I love that
what's up you did a good job he was
respectful yeah I don't know if he
washed his hands but about not washing
hands but that I'll be watching things
forever right in this lesson he washed
his hands but without so my question is
as well I'm super grateful for you did
and yeah my question is so I do
door-to-door sales for this company
called viven smart home and the reason
why I'm doing door-to-door sales it
could be arguably one of the hardest
sells that you could do yes I'm but more
importantly I'm getting sales skills
leadership skills people skills as well
as just
learning to grit in the grind I don't
really love what I do right now but I
understand the fact that I'm gaining a
lot of skills to fully develop and
hopefully became do become a
entrepreneur and my question is is what
I'm doing right now is that the right
steps to become a successful
entrepreneur it's not or are you asking
me if it is if it is well first and
foremost let's take a step back do you
have a sense of why you want to be an
entrepreneur yeah so I kind of the sense
that I have is I kind of had a taste my
mouth with the job that I have now with
becoming an entrepreneur you know
creating your own schedule working for
your own and on your own time like that
one yeah love and the flexibility is
just well as you know you like the sale
like you get high excited high energy
when somebody on a door-to-door says yes
yeah it's it's pretty invigorating just
knowing that I can knock a door and in
ten minutes I can make mom expect make
money but and McGee huh yeah
having someone trust me and not tell
Sally that she needs this thing exactly
yeah no look I think sales is an
incredible foundation to
entrepreneurship because I think a lot
of people might be good operators I see
a lot of people in my circles and a lot
of people I've worked with that are
great at operating something being a
manager but they aren't a great
salesperson and say and money and the
ability to sell to make money is the
oxygen of a business so I do think
you're building a foundational piece
there's a lot of other things that go
into entrepreneurship you know managing
people for sure is a huge one that has
nothing to do with what you're doing
now for say unless you're managing a
team and motivating so that you're
getting into that a little bit but
you're not the same place I think
different things that nature but yeah I
think i think it's a core piece and i
think this young of an age and i think
asking you those questions of like
you know just even your smile to like
yeah I like it like having love for the
clothes is a big piece bro now what will
really be interesting is are you the
kind of kid that's better off making 100
to 800 K being a head of sales for a
company versus being the owner of a
business is real you know to make that
same 100 to 800,000 that's a big deal
there's a lot of people that have
businesses right now that do 2 million a
year and they take home 3 10 and they
don't fully love it but if they were
just a head of sales of a company they'd
be making 5 90 and loving life because
they wouldn't have to have all the
baggage of all the pressure on their
[ __ ] shoulders I think that's the
crossroads that you have to figure out
are you a big-time salesperson or do you
want to be an owner operator of a
business and you won't know that until
you actually kind of go through the reps
but you should know that we're in a time
right now where entrepreneurs on this
pedestal is [ __ ] cool and yeah that's
what's freaking you [ __ ] what's cool
focus on what makes you happy
[ __ ] that entrepreneurship is cool you
love it and then do it because if you
don't you might be much happier loving
it being a head of sales or just being a
sales person and something you love
selling yeah bro don't get caught up in
the hype because let me tell you
something now this Corona thinks it's
for a while onto the worship is not
gonna be cool ok stable job is gonna be
cool you know what I mean like yeah is
you know now that nobody's gonna be able
to read I got [ __ ] a hundred emails on
LinkedIn yesterday of people begging me
for help because they lost their funding
entrepreneurship school when somebody
else is paying for it but I built their
businesses now do what he thinks you
have to raise money a lot of people have
been built their business from scratch
that's real grind and right now the
money's not gonna be flowing to [ __ ]
25-year olds with ideas and so just
figure out if you love entrepreneurship
or do you love sales and you're young
enough to try both and then take it from
there
all right so when I'm
trying to get into right now I have a
team like I have about six people that
are underneath me trying to become that
leader try to get into the manager role
so I'm trying to get a little taste of
that but would you recommend an any
other way to taste the Entrepreneurship
that you're talking about there's
something in bulk and try to sell it on
Amazon and eBay okay learning supply and
demand is another great thing you can do
on the side and figure out if you like
selling product okay literally take
whatever you can afford take you know
500 bucks a thousand bucks buy something
and flip it it is an incredible skill of
learning how to market and sell and
supply and demand so you just don't make
it hand sanitiser to be a douche bag
yeah
or toilet paper I love entrepreneurship
of exploitable spheres is lowest form so
cool bro I'm not today I'll talk you
soon all right sounds good Gary bean
thank you of course later man Ashley
Alex all right let's get our [ __ ]
together this morning boys and girls
people are tuning in TV carry these
clunky Alex what's good Alex just takes
a second Alex how are you what's up Gary
man it's cool go talking to him head
we'll talk to you where you from I'm
from North Carolina North Raleigh
awesome and how old are you I'm 16 I'm a
junior in high school right now you get
you enjoying this vacation of what I
mean it's it's kind of cool but I mean
it is what it is can't complain
look it was excited it was exciting at
first but now you realizing like being
stuck in the house is like some [ __ ]
yeah it's just tempers look like
everything man I can't do like anything
anymore forget it what can I answer for
you bro so my question is to you Gary
I want a major in music
performance in college okay but my mom
is heavily discouraging me and she won't
she's I'm willing to pay for my tuition
or so she says at the moment right so I
probably trick her and like sign up for
the major that she wants and then second
day of school go in and switch your
major yeah I thought about that yeah
yeah I mean what she can do at that
point or or Superman up and go into debt
or work a side job and pay for it
yourselves and those are really the two
moves right or yeah of course for number
three give it a college try on what she
wants you to do some [ __ ] that she
thinks is safe and will pay more based
on the world that she grew up in not
where the world's going or around your
passion and eat [ __ ] for a year and give
it a shot
who knows you really got three simple
hair of course you know like good news
we're all good options I wouldn't do
weather of course no I have a lot of
respect and empathy for sixteen year
olds like five this sucks like it's it's
like you know I remember the [ __ ] I
worried about we all worry about you can
that you can't worry about the biggest
everyone worries about their life right
so yeah I don't look down on this worry
at the same token I'm super happy
because I think all three options you
have are all awesome yeah of course
thank you Mary yeah man it's really just
putting things in perspective like you
thought you [ __ ] won you're gonna be
like all three are gonna be good like
you know like even if you even if you
decide what does she want you to major
it she wants me to do accounting which I
you know I want to be an entrepreneur
any musician which I know it seems a lot
but see you just wants me to do
accounting she just wants you to do
something that she thinks is safe
because she loves her I know understand
and so you know look I mean getting
getting some foundational understanding
of deeper financial infrastructure
probably won't hurt you so maybe you
sign up for that four-year one and see
what happens maybe you'll be surprised
take away some value or maybe after a
month you like [ __ ] this [ __ ] and you go
switch your major yeah but like in the
music in college you have to audition
like to get into music program once you
first apply to the school and so he
got it got it so look a couple things
what do you wanted what do you want to
be with the music oh I want to be I
wanna do saxophone and piano performance
and jazz so one of the things I like
about the game of merit of skill is it's
a skill game obviously people that go to
the top schools are gonna have a quote
unquote easier path to the league it's
like going to Florida or Alabama or USC
or Michigan for college football but the
NFL is is riddled with guys that went to
JUCO that you know that didn't have good
college career they're the [ __ ] Tom
Brady was a backup his last year in
college which is why he went 6th round
but if you're the [ __ ] goat you're
the goat and so one thing to keep in
mind is even if you don't go down the
path of getting into a great music
school if you're [ __ ] good enough at
the [ __ ] saxophone you're gonna be
able to do it
yeah like nip right now like they don't
just look for the schools like post
[ __ ] videos on tik-tok of you
crushing the [ __ ] sacks like that
like the world the world is so [ __ ]
different bro you're so blessed to be
living in this time when it's not just
like if you don't go to Julliard you
know like you know like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
like yeah of course it's different now
so just remember that if your path isn't
going and trying out for school and then
going to that school and then getting
into the performance but your path goes
around it and good news if you also want
to be an entrepreneur that's never
[ __ ] straight path so getting used to
zigging and [ __ ] zag knows
I almost hearing that you want to be
music and and entrepreneur almost don't
want you to go to a music school and
want you to do some [ __ ] like videos
on the corner of the [ __ ] Street
crushing the saxophone having people
come to you and then somebody wants you
to perform again you know what I mean
yeah guys good man hope you have a great
damn you'd say thank you man
UK writer take care all right Dustin
let's go fast
I like speed
Matt's gonna travel more time I told him
to take off his headphones so Nomad
another chance you know I'm I'm an
empathetic person all right all right
Matt hey you hear me better yeah fire
away
what can I answer so the question was uh
Mike uh how do you stay focused and keep
yourself on task to achieve more overall
success just in general in the macro
like specifically yeah take the take the
notepad away like on some real [ __ ] do
you find yourself not being able to stay
focused yeah they're the phone have you
thought about the fact that you just
might not like what you're doing I did
think about that but I think I heard
Jenny said it may not be that you lack
passion maybe that you like a calendar
and so I think that's really the problem
because I definitely like love what I'm
doing I work at Nickelodeon I'm an
animator what's up that's fine yeah so
what's happened like you also might love
the craft of animation you just might
not love the structure of Nickelodeon um
it's not really so much at work it's
more after work well what do you want to
happen after work uh I want to get more
things done with time that I have after
work so I want to I want work on
personal animation products of my own I
want to work on a outside of animation
to I want to get other things done like
I kind of want to make a podcast or
write an app or something towards like
yeah I'm kind of a meditation
self-development kind of app and so
other passions that I have so what
happens you you get home and you just
[ __ ] want to watch TV and like video
games and chill and talk to friends like
you don't get going
well so I I have a three hour commute to
and from work okay and then at work I'm
usually there eight to nine hours so I
usually don't get home until around
eight o'clock makes sense at that point
it's like I need to go to sleep around
11:30 so I can wake up to do it all over
again of course I feel like I get home I
eat dinner I mean maybe I do a little
you know talk to my family
maybe they available but I don't feel
like I have the time to be proactive or
even actually sometimes the time to do
things that I like to do like just fun
things so it's kind of like trying to
find like I'm trying to find a balance
of being able to be productive but still
have time for other things all right it
seems like I can't do either it's a lot
of sense and have you considered rooming
with like three people and like a shitty
apartment closer to Nickelodeon I
actually I lived in Manhattan I live in
New York which is where I work so I
lived in Manhattan which was only 15
million that's away my bike look
expensive J there was it too expensive
well I did for two years and at some
point yeah I became too expensive so I
decided move acting with my family in
the Bronx it's a little further but I
save a lot more money but I did do that
for two years and why didn't why not it
was it was still like even though I got
like why the Bronx takes three hours to
commute are you saying our and a half
each way
I don't know happy trip yeah so but so
what time do you leave work usually 6:30
got it yeah I mean look I think there's
a couple things that runs what about
weekends what are you doing on the
weekend usually I have the weekends free
but I usually like to spend it with my
girlfriend or my family
and that's again like it's it's a
difficult thing because I want to spend
time my family and my girlfriend and my
friends I want to have that that time to
get things done this thing the biggest
thing that I think how old are you 23
yeah you know my answer and I'm sure
Jays answer makes sense and I'm sure a
lot of people have answers my answer is
I think you're beating yourself up too
much I think you're being impatient for
the side stuff
okay like you know you know I didn't
really start like doing what I needed to
be doing for myself I was 34 with
Boehner right like I was kind of it in
the liquor store building business from
my family so I'm not I'm just thinking
at 23 in a world where you do want to
spend time with friends and family what
you think is healthy when you do have a
job that you actually like and you're
good at pay bills like save money that's
smart you're back home I love that the
humility to do that like I kind of like
everything you're doing except I think
you might just be impatient and might be
beating yourself up too much like why
can't you do the other things that you
want at 32
I'm being serious now thirty [ __ ]
child ya know I've always thought that
23 it's hard to think 30 choose a child
yeah I've always thought that that uh
when I guess in my 20s I'm like oh my
god things are running out of time and
then I see your videos and I was like
what show like I'm not even close to 30
yet I have so much time so I feel like I
have unlimited time up 44 I'm double
your [ __ ] you know like I think you
need to slow down you beating yourself
up if you start a podcast in two years
that'd be super young and super early I
just think I think you're overanalyzing
and beating yourself up too much okay I
really do like I get that you want to do
side projects and start a podcast and
build a [ __ ] app and we all have
ambitions but when it starts turning
into something that's negatives like
ambition is a very interesting game i
watch people to convert ambition like a
chemical into something very negative
and I see people turning into something
very positive I think you need to try to
convert it into like that you don't suck
and you're unmotivated and you [ __ ]
need meditation or drugs or like or a
[ __ ] cult to be a part of like you
can just take a step back and [ __ ]
realize you're doing so much grown you
just lay down some real [ __ ] [ __ ]
that I respect hard at a craft that you
like you're [ __ ] you had the humility
to move back in with your family at a
young age to be thoughtful about saving
money you're meaningfully spending time
with friends family and your girlfriend
you're doing a ton of [ __ ] right I'm
sorry that you haven't [ __ ] started
the great
and next meditation app yet or the
[ __ ] who on podcast I'm sorry that
you're not calm or [ __ ] Joe Rogan yet
but you're [ __ ] 23 yeah take a step
back and realize how many things you're
doing that are smart and give yourself a
little bit of breathing room like like
save some money
enjoy your early 20s you can start
getting serious a forty to let alone 27
you need to slow it down your your
ambition or ideology is creating anxiety
that it doesn't need to create in a
world where you're gonna live for and
let me say it slowly to your face
another [ __ ] 90 years yeah you
understand yeah thank you for saying all
that sense yeah I get it I feel like
that is what I do and I feel like I can
see it myself okay even and I gotta slow
down with like being impatient about
like I want to get things done right um
but like what what do you think I should
do until then - at least at least feel
like the time that I have work it's
still something productive realize that
relaxation is productive realize that
you know just like like in like kind of
like slowing down a little bit catching
up with friends at 8:30 is a [ __ ]
good productive thing like productivity
doesn't have to come in the form of the
output of a business thing or an output
of a making of something in my just
productivity for your soul and for
Humanity is [ __ ] great and by the way
the weekends you might be able to find
three hours to be cuz your pop committed
to 48 hours that's the thing that's the
thing is so I see my girlfriend usually
two to two-and-a-half days of the three
dude weekend the three-day weekend you
know make sense I really uh I don't see
it here in the weekdays much I want to
spend that time three weeks but when I
get home let's say it's like Sunday end
of Sunday I'm like okay I have a few
hours left in this day then at this
point it's like I feel like it's me
that's that's getting in the way because
it's not that I'm out of time in that
situation it's that I can't get myself
to just sit down and do something stop
beating yourself up and realize that
right this second at 23 a [ __ ] child
you're just not motivated to do the
podcast or
mm it's okay one of the greatest
strengths that I have is not beating
myself up by plenty of times where I can
just like take a whole year and not be
as productive as I want or miss operate
the business for a year like just don't
beat yourself up like you will do it
when you're ready and you want to hmm
you know what I mean or you know I would
I would spend that time I would take
down time into consuming information
that might lead to an unlock for you but
don't think of this as a negative dude
okay enough with that like you're not
lazy you're not unmotivated you don't
have a blockage like you just don't want
to do it right now I don't know I think
I think I really want to do it but I
don't know you don't your idea you think
you want you the ideology is to do it
but your actions are actions over words
bro if you wanted to do a podcast you
[ __ ] run after hanging out with your
girlfriend on Sunday at 4 p.m. and come
in and [ __ ] build your podcast you
like the idea of the podcast you like
the idea of the app you like the idea
but right now you don't want to do it so
you think I want to do it just not yet
maybe I also scared that you want to do
it because theoretically it looks good
to you and your ideology versus it's
actually in your [ __ ] soul I mean I
I'm nanometre at Nickelodeon which is
great I love animation but but I think
my real passion is out is actually
helping people and then focus on content
let's start there oh good like let's
focus on tick-tock lay in your bed
Sunday afternoon literally flip the
phone and [ __ ] the lighting look at how
shitty our both settings are right now
and just talk to the [ __ ] kids you
want to help people there's a [ __ ]
there's an unlimited amount of kids on
tick-tock there's an unlimited amount of
opportunity right now on tick-tock to
get organic reach when nobody knows who
the [ __ ] you are there's an unlimited
opportunity for you look at the trending
hashtags pick one talk about figure out
how you want to talk about it and tell
kid a story about how at 23 right now
you're struggling and I know you're 16
and I'm still a kid I talked to Gary me
last week and they're like you want to
help people good news it's called the
flip your [ __ ] camera around and talk
to the [ __ ] world
tik-tok specifically because you'll get
reach because that platform still has an
organic reach and you'll be able to help
a bunch of kids and you were just a kid
four minutes ago talk right everybody
wants to help the world but then they
want to make it complicated and build
like a seven trillion dollar app that
costs a lot of money as slow and takes
nine months and raise capital and find a
[ __ ] development partner
it's all [ __ ] I'm practical take your
[ __ ] phone slip into your [ __ ]
beautiful face and [ __ ] tell somebody
something okay makes sense yeah it make
sense scratch that edge if you like me
if you like Shetty like I get it I'm
listening to you right cool try it try
it just tell a story right now people
should tell stories tell a [ __ ] story
on tick-tock call it story time right
with [ __ ] Matt you know and just say
tell a story be like hey when I was 16
this fucked-up thing happened and I got
through it
and you can too and that just might help
one [ __ ] kid on the other side and
then you'll scratch the itch of helping
I just wanted to say one more thing my
brother he's a huge fan you too he
wanted me to ask you a question yeah
yeah quick I just wanted to know how do
you how would you recommend bouncing
look like having fun with with school
and work and all anything that's that
needs to be you know something you need
to have to do you guys clearly share DNA
this is yeah that's very similar
question but see rich imagining it not
from my situation where he hits it's
just he has a lot of things to do and
it's not that he doesn't have to drive
for something else it's just how does he
actually find time between things I
guess is what he wants or so you guys
share DNA this is about judgment
I'm telling you about judgment about rim
you know what I mean like you gotta take
a step back and and the answer isn't
whatever let it go
like don't overanalyze balance just
[ __ ] live life and stop [ __ ]
overthinking [ __ ] for who for what okay
thank you all right Dustin let's get
this going thanks Matt good question
good [ __ ] this is fun see with Gary B
everybody yeah
okay yes
hey sorry I had customers customers
first always I was taught that a long
time ago
alright but my first question I would
did have a question because I had a
moment where I was like maybe this is
not gonna work out for me so I have a
smoothie business and my husband and I
we've been trying to expand in Houston
and I guess it's so hard can you see all
your colleagues they're expanding in
their cities like everyone's like on
fire and then you're like ignore it
focus on what you're doing you're doing
the right thing and some days it's like
I would think maybe I'm not really cut
out for this but the other day I was
thinking I was like I'm totally cut out
for this you like it yeah I really like
it let's stop for a second before
whether you're cut out to be an
entrepreneur or not definitely before
like who gives a [ __ ] about how other
people are clicking nobody's life or
expansion of their [ __ ] smoothie shop
or bakery or [ __ ] cookie shop we
spend so much time in nd about how
somebody else is growing it's just a
complete and utter waste of [ __ ] time
if you start with you like it and I kind
of believe you like I watched it with
the customer and even just the way you
just answered so I actually believe you
which excites me well you need to spend
a hundred percent of your time on is the
customer like spend every minute that
you're worried about Melissa's milk shop
and Karen's cookie shop every second
that you spend on that focus on your
[ __ ] customer ask them like that
customer you deserved ask them what like
hey what else could be served here that
would excite you what else do you want
like how do you like it like a complete
obsession about your customer at you
like it complete obsession about your
customer everything else has a real high
chance of working out it doesn't matter
if you're cut out for it or not whether
you debate it in your head or your
uncle's debating it behind your back I'm
deciding from the sidelines it actually
doesn't matter what ends up happening
ends up mattering including you failing
in this venture and then restarting it
a year and a half later with a different
spin on it and [ __ ] winning that time
and then being able to shove in
everybody's face who said you weren't
good enough and most of all most of all
Ashley if you like it you're [ __ ]
winning you have to understand that if
you actually like it you're winning
there's plenty of people who are
building successful us our companies or
who are making a ton of money in their
job who hated who are losing compared to
you
I'd rather stress about making a
mortgage payment cuz my business sucks
[ __ ] but love building that business
then [ __ ] having a [ __ ] golf club
membership but [ __ ] hating my job
because that's [ __ ] 50% of your life
you take away sleeping [ __ ] work is
that I mean are you kidding me if you
[ __ ] love it you [ __ ] one of
course we want it to be successful but
debating whether you're cut out word
right now or not or worrying about
somebody house doing well his dog should
[ __ ] that agreed right yeah I mean I do
love it I love what I do I we've been
doing this on for two years I take care
of the business myself
my husband's really might read in the
background and I left I been toiling
gasps I'm in school and it's not that I
hated my 8 to 5 I just hated the
lifestyle that I had and here it's like
I get freedom I do work way more than
what I used to work but I love what I
get to do like the impact that I have on
people and are you guys in trouble right
now cause of Corona our numbers have
been affected but I watched your live
yesterday so I really liked all those
tips that you were giving on small
businesses like doing the videos so I
have a different marketing plan for my
next 90 days because my my usual
marketing is not gonna work with what's
going on right now
I'm sorry what's your usual marketing my
usual marketing is business of business
and we schedule people for like a
smoothie day so it's very one-on-one
percent but it draws in a lot of people
need people that week this is the time
to build brand
around Ashley the human being and your
company you need to put out two videos
three videos today one on Instagram one
on Facebook one on tick-tock you have to
promise me that actually it is videos
about you that will make this business
grow I mean it tell your story your
story if I was in oil and gas but I
[ __ ] hated it and did this will
resonate with 43% of Houston like yeah
you know like listen to me put yourself
out there right literally hang up right
now take this positive energy and take
your [ __ ] phone and make a video and
just be like here's me and just
literally [ __ ] post it on the
Instagram start a tik-tok account
yesterday yesterday you have a tick tock
account for the business yet no but
literally hang up right now take the
energy and make one don't know how
Google how to sign up for tick tock
account do you know what I mean control
yeah
don't think about the strategy [ __ ]
do the strategy right now maybe your
business ignite ignite nutrition and do
you have an Instagram account yeah and
what is it
ignite nutrition club [ __ ] is this your
brand arisen like yeah we made up the
name awesome beautiful
iced coffee so they're huge in Texas
good I just followed you now here's a
good thing I just followed you here's
the bad thing I'm gonna [ __ ] stop the
[ __ ] out of your account and make sure
that you're doing what I'm talking about
listen to me put make videos about you
and your story do it right now use some
hashtags in your post and then making
tick-tock right now I want to tick tocks
from you a day every day I'm telling you
right now you're gonna send me a crying
happy email in seven weeks about
what happened with tick tock and your
business are you offering
are you offering delivery yeah those
hearts because only me right now and I
have a girl who comes and helps me she's
my friend but mostly people are coming
in and for take-out or curbside
understood make [ __ ] content make a
lot of it you're [ __ ] sitting around
with less customers foot traffic don't
sit and well and think and debate if
you're cut out for this make [ __ ]
videos now I I want to see a video I
want you to make a video of every
individual drink you have how you make
it and have you thought about it so make
the video and post it on Instagram
tik-tok Facebook yes alright you have a
Twitter account
damn create a Twitter account post it
they're making [ __ ] content is how
small businesses will get out of Corona
okay yeah bye hi
alright teeth Gary Biggs vice for all
hear everybody's listening I see a ton
of comments from everybody that they're
happy with the advice they got yesterday
they're happy with your vice they got
today but I need [ __ ] action I need
[ __ ] action from all of you [ __ ]
me
who's next dust its Darcy hi Darcy hi
how are you
well how are you good thanks what's
cooking so my question for you is how do
you deal with a negative friend you
limit your interaction with them okay
it's real life like a friend is not to
be cut out a friend is to be quarantined
he's basically needed your friend what
you're doing to the coronavirus okay
you're gonna have to spend less time
with them you should also be upfront
with them that you're gonna be doing
that and then you're and that you love
them I mean obviously you're already
getting emotional so this is a longtime
friend yes best friend
no but core friend yeah for sure
that's awesome listen it's the kids it's
the kids meaning she's got kids and
so they try and keep in contact and
stuff like that so one more time
hurricane kids keep in contact with me
that's sweet yeah and so it's been hard
because she's super negative and I want
to keeping huh and and they're keeping
in contact with you because they're
getting positivity from you I'm guessing
I'm not a hundred percent sure but
ii-i've been a friend with her for a
really long time and she her kids like
looked to me as like an an just kind of
thing which is awesome but um you can be
there for them without interacting with
your friend as much and I'm sure that
that will be up and your friend will
reach out to me and be like [ __ ] you
[ __ ] like you're not talking to me I'm
not gonna usually make Facebook posts
about it what's that I don't feed into
it I don't feed into the negativity and
then she should go and post on Facebook
about how without using my name
but subtweet I get it so listen to me
doing that doing the right thing is
always the right thing just long enough
emotionally to deal with the subtle jabs
even though it hurts your heart yeah for
sure and you're doing this for the kids
which is incredibly noble yes I also
think at some point it's not against the
idea of potentially reaching out to her
and having dinner and really going there
with her and telling her that you love
her and you know maybe that one
conversation sparks her going to therapy
or recognizing something in her like I
always think a last-ditch effort with
compassion but candor right when you mix
compassion with candor right when you're
not attacking or you're like I love you
but this I [ __ ] I you know I think
you'll always feel good when you're 92
that you to many people cut people out
or tell you them to [ __ ] themselves back
I think you go with compassion and
candor and it's something that you are
grateful you did when you're 90 years
old you feel like you did it all that
you could right yes okay I like that
idea you know what I mean like yeah
that'd be like listen here
I'm empathetic to you this is DNA and
parenting and environment my friends our
whole lives you know but you but listen
this is really tough and this is like
tough on me I find myself pulling away
because the negativity is unbearable
your kids you know I want to be them I
love them because I love you like is
there anything I can do to help you like
like please like tell me
[ __ ] you [ __ ] Darcy you think you're
better I'm better than you I just love
you and I know what's happening and and
then because you know are you like this
is why doesn't talk to you anymore this
is why Rick broke up with you in college
like look I like but I'm here I've been
here and I don't want to disappear but I
sustained this like level of cynicism
negativity right like what can I do for
you right now to help that level that
kind of delivery give you a fighter's
chance' a puncher's chance to maybe fix
it yes and I'd like to help her because
she's got such a damaged past in her
life that I'd like to be a positive
support but she just puts so much on me
that I can't especially with everything
in the world right now I'm learning how
who is really super negative and who's
gonna come out positive and we just
choose to be positive so it's hard to
even hear any of this negativity and if
you look at China South Korea even Italy
in the last 24 hours like if you look
carefully there's plenty to be positive
we're all gonna get through this yeah
and by the way some people can lose jobs
and some people gonna lose family
members like it's tough but yeah some
people people look at the negative I'm
saying friends like hey I know you're
scared but what if if the Corona thing
didn't happen you were living your
normal life and today was the day that
you were gonna get hit by a car crossing
the road
and died right one looks at the obvious
negative instead of the not obvious
negative there's a lot of things that
are gonna happen today
stayed home and didn't do something that
they would have done in real life that
would have left to their death or
unhappiness right so they didn't even
know correct so anyway listen to me okay
lesson him compassion and candor okay
two good words I think so and when you
mix
together and they're cut and and you
come from a good place which clearly
you're coming from yes if nothing else
when you're 92 you would have done the
best you could have that's what I wanted
only want what's best for her but she
doesn't want to hear it correct which
means that you have to come at it from a
different angle and may need a mix of
compassion and candor
because what kandar's been very hard for
me over my 44 years I've gotten better
at it but I'm still not there positive
people tend to struggle with delivering
negative points if you know yes yeah I
mean a frank conversation with you and
saying you're [ __ ] negative as [ __ ]
at least something that doesn't come
natural to you given how I owe you
already right I get it I'm gonna say it
again
I'm compassion with candor might be
something that works might be okay well
it's a good angle to take anyways that's
that's all I was looking for so I'm
happy to deliver it you're the best
you're the best I'll see you later thank
you it's really nice good one Darcy all
right where we going next brother we
have Becky thank you I like this run of
ladies hi good morning morning Becky
thank you for your time today my
question I'm getting so much great
information from what you're answering
from others but I am in the health field
I'm a health coach and with a very heart
based service industry like many other
people this has sparked us to want to do
more and in fact I was thinking of Matt
earlier today and thinking maybe if he
thought about who he was serving it
would spark him to get motivated but
what I'm running into you is I want to
give everything away for free and while
I want to and plan on and had had
planned on and now have great ideas for
more content I also have to charge and
you know provide for my family so my
question is where do you draw that line
we want to put tons of great content out
and I have a program starting but if it
were up to me I would do it and never be
paid but the bills will come so that's
kind of
so this is something of a fine line that
I think I've done really well in the
last ten years well I think it's about
intent and I like what you're intense at
let me give you a really good point of
view I think where you draw the line is
at intent let me explain
I think anytime you put out content you
need to put out the best possible
content you can for free the problem is
you're getting voices that are telling
you hey don't be a sucker you got to
provide for your family you know whether
this is your internal voice or outside
people like don't be too soft you have
to charge for this your time is valuable
your expertise is valuable that all is
true but information content is actually
a commodity there's an unlimited amount
of free content on the internet for
every business person that's charging 99
dollars for an e-book or five thousand a
month to be part of a club I'm putting
out better [ __ ] information for free
let me explain you take this in your
mind put out all the content for free
and the best content that you possibly
can
don't put out content that's tricking
people to sign up for your membership
put out great content and then realize
what you're actually selling on the
membership side is actually access not
content okay right access to me right
well back like you consume Oh obviously
if you're on this call You Know Who I am
and you've consumed my content right
right doing for you right now I'm going
very detailed to your actual situation I
just provided intentionally more value
in 49 seconds than I have in a year
worth of free content because you've got
access to me and I could get context and
I can go deeper so I've got it I think
the balancing act is put out unlimited
free content and [ __ ] save the world
like I love doing well but then to make
your business create a access variable
that that's what somebody's really
paying for right and I like because a
lot of times when people like well
premium content is what I'm charging for
and here's what's really happening there
is most of the free content is really
just a gateway and manipulation content
to get people to pay for yeah
membership and that's why it doesn't
feel good to you but if you flip it and
you say here's all my best content for
free which is then gonna lead to people
trusting and loving me and if they can
afford and are interested in access see
right how I sweat yes and then I have
another challenge that I'm hearing this
is different from other people that have
been on the calls that other people may
be able to relate to I'm a mom as well
and I work from home and so a lot of
people are feeling I have all this extra
time but now I have my child at home
that I'm helping several hours a day
with homework and so it's actually
taking away from the time I would spend
on my business um so I'm having to be
very mindful about everything that I'm
doing but also is being in help I can't
not sleep I need to you know walk a walk
so it's that's a big challenge that's
coming up and I'm just one and god bless
people who have more than one is he or
she in he's in third grade third yeah
and it sounds like it wouldn't be a lot
of work but I'm telling you it's like
four hours a day but honestly two things
one you know I have a very passionate
point of view on this hey it's just not
like to me for example if he missed all
third grade curriculum between now and
the end of the year but he spent an hour
talking with you walking around the
block I believe this one man's point of
view I'm not necessarily right I believe
that's a greater impact on his life when
he's 27 then getting his cursive writing
or base multiplication down that being
said I don't get to parent your child
you do I would say this take it from
somebody who checked the [ __ ] out by
third grade don't over worry about this
thought that if you don't crush these
four hours a day that your four son is
gonna be behind in fourth grade right
right well we have that mindset my
husband and I for sure and we're we're
outdoor people and and so yeah then then
let them [ __ ] have summer vacation
mad [ __ ] like that yeah
I mean the snow yeah what's it you I
understand and I'm fine the right don't
overthink the ideology like like
reverse-engineer the reaction reality of
the situation don't let those four hours
create anxiety for you while you have to
also previous financial stability and
stay healthy
I would wildly argue out of help your
own health and building financial
stability fear family that the
curriculum part of the third grade four
hours per day is by far the least
important of course you wanted to learn
discipline but there's a lot this is a
huge opportunity for you to do a lot of
different things with him so just I
would I would think big on this yeah so
it's so you know part of his having him
do something while I'm on these very
intimate one-on-one calls with clients
and I don't want him on you know I've
had all day doing something unproductive
fine I I would argue that that might I
would argue him exploring the iPad and
navigating a technology communication
infrastructure is potentially more
productive than him doing [ __ ] some
sheets that the teacher made you print
out I think technology you're [ __ ]
trying to build an entire life a
business around using technology you and
I are talking to each other right now
through technology had there been no if
this [ __ ] Corona happen in eighty
eight we'd all be [ __ ] not
interacting really isolated we demonize
technology when technology brings
happiness I would argue your son would
learn more by exploring that iPad
whether that's watching cartoons on
YouTube kids or not I am not convinced
that him following the state mandated
curriculum of third grade every [ __ ]
kid and I like how you're laughing about
this again like rather you spend two of
the four hours really digging through
the internet to finding some unique
things that he could unique apps you
need if you spent two hours of the four
hours right now today looking at all
YouTube kids shows and all kids apps and
creating your own curriculum let him
watch little me and become a [ __ ]
entrepreneur let him watch a compassion
so for kids
mr. Rogers like I would argue do not
demonize the functionality of an iPad
don't put paper on a pedestal and a
compute and a laptop not you know what I
mean yeah the mechanism yeah my husband
would high-five you because he's in the
technical field and he's like this
handwriting he's never going to use it
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
thank you sir I have one more thing
everyone makes a request of you I want
to offer you a gift
okay so somewhere in the future if you
ever need help with health in your
office in your business that's something
that I do and I would love to help I
love it so send me an email - Gary yeah
and say it's Becky with kids it's on the
iPad in touch with Claude all right all
right take care
Instagram I'm not gonna hold this any
more
there's a link to this live on my
facebook it's in my Instagram URL right
now
what's up moon dog Rex a tiny little man
and he's on now Andrew just so you know
it's 9:55 everybody got a cut today well
some will do two hours tomorrow again I
think is that right Dustin is that way
yeah okay I got to go to a finance
meeting for Boehner so we like [ __ ] so
let's sneak in we're sure moment so
first of all thank you very heaven me on
but basically my question was if I want
to make it kind of content but I feel
might ostracize me from the people that
are closest to me how do I get over that
fear I apologize I was unfortunate not
paying attention one more time no my
question was if I am in like intending
to make a kind of concept right through
youtube new media Instagram chick talk
all that stuff and I feel like there's a
possibility that it could ostracize me
from the people that are closest to me
by the nature of it how do I get over
that what's the move easy by realizing
that anybody who'd be ostracized or not
like you as much
I'm talking about something that you're
passionate and interested in talking
about is somebody is not something that
you need to be valuing they need to love
doctor you all of you all the true of
you like you what are you gonna live a
fake life like you know
you're gonna maintain friends and family
predicated on things that you'd like
you're literally not gonna talk about
the things that you want to talk about
in life because you friended your mom or
your uncle or your sister or your homies
are gonna think it's weird or on a pro
inappropriate or like you know what that
you don't want those friendships anyway
I mean that
don't underestimate friends and family
they tend to step up mmm okay it's an
interesting people I like the way you
reacted and I've never really said that
before my son you know this team with
Gary meeting might be good like we
underestimate parents friends and family
I think they tend to step up more
because a lot because 80% of them
actually love you and they want for your
true self I think you need to put out
the things you need to put out in the
world cool okay is it political is it
sexual is it weird like what is it not
even that serious
no like basically like firstly I've like
never been myself my whole [ __ ] life
like that's just the fact of it because
actually go ahead because you know
because based like essentially no one
knows that I swear like a sailor like no
one knows like my interest and [ __ ] like
that just because it's like I feel like
probably because what's up you have to
be a good boy
exactly exactly but like the the content
that I want to make I wanted to be as
honest as possible because I want a
document like essentially growing up
like when you're way [ __ ] behind like
I'm 23 and like I'm in a spot where it's
like I have to become like a real person
and I feel like it's something a lot of
people can relate to and I want to
document that journey one just to have
the content of it to practice for the
future and also in case anyone like
needs any help they can pull from that
but the biggest thing is like it'll make
me it'll force me to be accountable to
actually do the [ __ ] you know what I
mean so that's kind of where where this
is coming from you're gonna win
this I love everything I just heard
you're not behind your back to yourself
aware that you've never been yourself is
a huge win it's the first step most
people can't see the first step a sixty
four percent of the people in your life
are gonna step up and love you so much
for this and the thirty six percent that
won't we'll get over it in six months
[Laughter]
all right brother hey man I appreciate
know I didn't really get three most
worried about your mom or do you most
with family of course my mom yeah yeah
dude your mom mom's your mom will love
you like maybe your sailor mouth for a
little bit maybe a couple weeks maybe it
will tear down the ideology that you're
this perfect little saint but she's
gonna love you cold bro hmm true facts
man thank you know what I mean
absolutely I needed that so secretly be
proud of you that's the truest [ __ ] yeah
yeah talk to you soon take care
alright everybody hope you enjoyed
today's episode of tea with Gary B I'm
super excited to be doing this show like
when the cheese gets cold by the end I
see life is good [ __ ] too I appreciate
all of you I'll see you tomorrow
9:00 a.m. Eastern I hope this brought
value my team will now be chopping up a
ton of content we couldn't get out
further throughout the day I love you
Dustin thank you so much let's get
quicker on the ones and twos tomorrow
yes sir and I appreciate all of you have
a bleep great great great great great
day I promise you we'll look back at
this pandemic as long as you don't lose
a loved one as a good thing it is a
reset it is one step back two steps
forward you will find better jobs you
will start better businesses will learn
how to save you learn how to be grateful
for simplicity I love you all very much
miss you soon
[Music]